From NPR, this is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. If you had to choose a romantic partner, would you pick someone who was equally wonderful to everyone, including you, or someone who was especially wonderful to you? It's a question that fascinates Lalene Anik. I am an assistant professor at University of Virginia in Stardin School of Business. Lalene and her colleague, Ryan Ryan Hauser ran a set of studies to figure out if people want a partner whose equal opportunity in their attention or someone who reserved special treatment
来自NPR，这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。如果你必须选择一个浪漫的伴侣，你会选择一个对所有人都一样好（包括你），还是一个对你格外好的人？这个问题让拉琳·阿尼克非常着迷。我是弗吉尼亚大学达顿商学院的助理教授。拉琳和她的同事瑞安·豪泽做了一系列研究，旨在弄清楚人们究竟是想要一个在注意力上一视同仁的伴侣，还是想要一个保留特殊对待的伴侣。
for them. What we find in the paper is people want to be treated uniquely. The urge to be treated special was so strong that people were willing to pay a price for it. Take the example of a birthday message. Imagine that your partner writes a Facebook message that is long and beautiful. But there's a catch. Your partner writes this sort of long, birthday message all the time for everyone.
我们在论文中发现的是，人们希望得到独特的对待。渴望被特殊对待的冲动如此强烈，以至于人们愿意为此付出代价。以生日祝福为例。想象一下，你的伴侣在Facebook上写了一条既长又美好的祝福。但问题来了。你的伴侣一直都在给所有人写这种又长又好的生日祝福。
If this message goes to everybody, people say, I don't want that beautiful, thoughtful message. Just tell me one line or that says, happy birthday. Why would people care so much about being singled out? That they'd accept an inferior message. If my partner sends me a beautiful message, that's a world in which she or he gives it to everybody else. And that pie might be bigger but it is divided
如果这条信息发给了所有人，人们就会说，我不要那个美丽、体贴的信息。只要告诉我一句话，或者说，生日快乐就行。为什么人们会如此在意被区别对待？以至于他们会接受一条逊色的信息。如果我的伴侣发给我一条美丽的信息，那就意味着她或他也会把这个发给其他人。那个蛋糕可能会更大，但它被分成了多份，而且我认为人们会有种自己分得变少了的感觉。在另一种情况下，他们发给我一条简短、几乎是生硬或冷淡的信息，但他们对其他人却不是这样的，这意味着整个蛋糕虽然可能更小，但它是我的。而且它全部属于我。我们当中有很多人希望伴侣把整个蛋糕都给我们。我们期望所爱的人让我们成为他们生活的中心，我们也期望回报以同样的方式。对我们爱的人倾注偏爱，不仅感觉很自然。
into multiple parts and I think people have the feeling that they're getting less. In the other world where they send me a short, almost curt or cold message but they don't do that for everybody else that means that the whole pie, although it might be smaller, it is mine. But it is all for me. So many of us want our partners to give us the whole pie. We expect our loved ones to make us the center of their lives and we expect to do the same in return. Showering favors on those we love doesn't just feel natural.
这感觉就像是一件值得庆祝的事。我们的Facebook和Instagram动态里到处都是人们描述他们如何将所爱之人奉若神明。但我们没有注意到的是，我们给予最亲近的人特殊对待的冲动，可能会带来可怕的道德后果。上周，我们探讨了我们当中实际上有多少人遵循“人人平等”这一最高准则。今天，我们试图理解为什么我们很难将这一价值观付诸实践，以及源于爱的行为如何会导致一个更加不公正的世界。
It feels like something to celebrate. Our Facebook and Instagram feeds are chock full of people describing how they've put their loved ones on a pedestal. But what we fail to notice is that our impulse to give special treatment to those closest to us can have terrible moral consequences. Last week, we looked at how few of us actually live by the maximum that everyone is equal. Today, we try to understand why we struggle to put that value into practice and how actions that come from a place of love can lead to a more unjust world.
偏心的罪过，本周《隐藏的大脑》。马扎林·班纳吉长期以来一直在研究歧视心理学。她关于这个主题的第一篇文章发表于1993年，自那以后她发表了数百篇研究论文。她还协助开发了隐式关联测验，数百万人曾使用该测验来识别他们的无意识偏见。鉴于她对我们对待他人方式的深刻思考，你可能会认为需要付出很多努力才能改变她对歧视的看法。
The sins of playing favorites this week on Hidden Brain. Maserine Banaji has been studying the psychology of discrimination for a long time. Her first article on the topic came out in 1993 and she's published hundreds of research papers since then. She's also helped to develop the implicit association test, which millions of people have used to identify their unconscious biases. Given how deeply she's thought about the ways we treat others, you might think it would take a lot to alter her views about discrimination.
但马扎林对偏见如何运作的理解，被两个词彻底重塑了。卡普兰教授。这两个词标志着她多年前听过的一个故事的转折点。这个故事关于马扎林的朋友兼同事卡拉·卡普兰。卡拉和马扎林现在都是马萨诸塞州的教授，卡拉在东北大学，马扎林在哈佛。但当时，他们都在耶鲁大学教书。卡拉是一个绝对才华横溢的年轻女性，能言善辩，才华横溢的作家，
But Mauserine's understanding of how bias plays out was radically reshaped by two words. Professor Kaplan. Those words marked a turning point in a story she first heard many years ago. The story was about Mazarene's friend and colleague, Carla Kaplan. Carla and Mazarene are now both professors and Massachusetts, Carla at Northeastern University and Mazarene at Harvard. But at the time, they both taught at Yale. Carla was this absolutely brilliant young woman, articulate beyond measure, gifted writer,
英语教授。但她还有这些美妙的其他爱好。我的意思是，她是个拼布被子制作者，你经常会看到她坐在演讲的后排，就像一个小巧的德法日夫人，你知道的，一边坐在那里做拼布，一边听关于18世纪文学的讲座。尽管在不同的部门工作，但因为她们俩在20世纪80年代的教授中有一个罕见的共同点，所以她们彼此熟悉了。
a professor of English. But she also had these wonderful other hobbies. I mean, she was a quilter, and you would often see her sitting in the back of a lecture like a little Madame de Farge, you know, sitting there quilting away while she listened to a talk on what an 18th century literature. Despite working in different departments, the two of them got to know each other because they shared a characteristic that was unusual for professors in the 1980s.
她们都是女性。在20世纪80年代末，像我们这样的年轻女性只能是两种人。如果她们像我们一样穿衣，她们看起来就像本科生。如果她们穿得更好一点，她们通常穿着行政助理的服装。校园里为数不多的女教授经常不期而遇。马扎林和卡拉就是这样认识的。我们彼此熟悉了，这就是我如何得知她的手的故事。一天晚上，卡拉在洗一个水晶碗时没拿稳。
They were women. In the late 1980s, young women who looked like us could only be two kinds of people. If they dressed like us, they looked like undergraduates. And if they dressed nicer, they typically wore administrative assistance. The few female professors on campus regularly crossed paths. That's what happened to Miserine and Carla. And we got to know each other, which is how I learned about the story of her hand. One night, Carla lost her grip on a crystal bowl she was washing.
碗撞到水槽上碎了。这个碗的锯齿状边缘把她的手从手掌中间一直割到了手腕。卡拉的厨房地板看起来像杰克逊·波洛克的画布。她的血到处飞溅。她的男友用一些绷带包扎了她的手。他赶紧把她送到急诊室。主治医生对她非常照顾，并一直安慰她会没事的。
The bowl hit the sink and shattered. The jagged edge of this bowl cut her hand from the middle of the palm to her wrist. Carla's kitchen floor looked like a Jackson Pollock canvas. Her blood was splattered everywhere. Her boyfriend patched up her hand with some bandages. He rushed her over to the emergency room. The attending doctor was very attentive to her, and kept reassuring her that she would be fine.
卡拉和她的男友试图让医生明白，保持卡拉手部的灵活性对她有多么重要。他们解释说她是一个拼布工。拼布需要精细的手指运动，他们希望这种缝合实际上能让她的手恢复所有的敏感度，并得到保证这确实会发生。在那一刻，没有理由认为她得到的不是最好的治疗。
Carla and her boyfriend tried to get the doctor to understand how important it was for Carla to preserve the dexterity in her hand. They explained that she was a quilter. Quilting requires fine finger movement, and they hoped that this stitching up would actually allow her to have all of her sensitivity back in her hands and were assured that indeed that would happen. And there was no reason to think in that moment that she wasn't receiving anything but the best treatment.
但卡拉很快发现她并没有得到最好的治疗。医院的一名志愿者恰好路过，认出了卡拉并说：“卡普兰教授，你在这里做什么？”医生惊呆了。他问卡拉：“你是耶鲁大学的教授？”在确认了这一信息后，卡拉被紧急送往大楼的另一个区域。新英格兰最好的手部专家被叫来，和一帮其他医生一起为她的手做手术，一直做到深夜。这比卡拉在急诊室接受的手术要广泛得多。
But Carla was about to discover that she was not getting the best treatment possible. A volunteer at the hospital happened to pass by, recognized Carla and said, Professor Kaplan, what are you doing here? The doctor froze. He asked Carla, your professor at Yale? Upon confirming that information rushed Carla off to a different part of the building. The best hand specialist in New England was called and with a bunch of other doctors operated on her hand for several hours into the night. It was far more extensive surgery than Carla would have received in the emergency room.
对她手部更精细神经的处理会花费极其漫长的时间。然后我也相信，人们对美容部分的关注度更高了。卡拉很感激能得到如此细致的照顾，但她的感激之情被另一种感觉所掩盖。她感到震惊。卡拉惊呆了，她是一个拼布工并不足以让她得到应得的治疗，但身为教授却可以。
The work on the finer nerves of her hand is what would have taken the incredibly longer time. And then I also believe that there was greater attention to the cosmetic part of it. Carla was grateful to receive such careful attention, but her gratitude was overshadowed by another feeling. She was appalled. Carla was just stunned that her being a quilter was not sufficient to get her the treatment that she should have gotten, but that being a professor did.
不知何故，医生一定没有像被“耶鲁教授”这个双词短语打动那样，被拼布工的故事所打动。当马扎林回想起这个故事时，它颠覆了她对偏见的理解，而这正是她职业生涯的核心焦点。如果卡拉在急诊室的医生因为她的种族、性别或其他特征而拒绝为她做手术，马扎林会立即认为发生的事情是歧视。我们所有人都会。但卡拉并没有被拒绝任何东西。
And somehow it must be that the doctor did not feel compelled by the quilter story in the same way as he was compelled by a two-word phrase Yale professor. When Maserine reflected on the story, it rattled her understanding of bias, the very focus of her career. Had Carla's doctor in the ER refused to perform surgery on her because of her race, or gender, or some other characteristic, Maserine would have immediately considered what happened to be discrimination. We all would. But Carla was not denied anything.
急诊室的医生和蔼、细心且能干。卡拉并没有受到比任何其他病人更差的对待。卡拉这个故事的重点不是放在医生做的负面事情上，即他扣留了对她的一些基本水平的关注。我们在这里谈论的是施以援手行为，这些行为超出了我们通常所做的范畴。卡拉故事核心的道德问题不是仇恨行为，而是特殊善良的行为。卡拉得到的超出了寻常。她得到了VIP待遇，这产生了巨大的影响。
The emergency room doctor was kind, attentive, and competent. Carla was not treated worse than any other patient. The point of the Carla story is to focus not so much on a negative thing that the doctor did, something where he, withheld some basic level attention to her. What we are speaking about here are acts of helping which are things that go above and beyond what we typically do. The moral problem at the heart of Carla's story was not an act of hate, but an act of special kindness. What Carla got went above and beyond the ordinary. She received VIP treatment, and it made a huge difference.
我很难想象，在急诊室里需要缝合的简单缝合工作，与持续数小时的精细手术相比，真的不会对这个人的生活产生实质性的影响。马扎林意识到，歧视的定义太狭隘了，无法涵盖这种类型的伤害。我们确实以老式的方式通过寻找作为行为来衡量偏见。我做了什么？我会不会穿过小镇去烧毁一个不属于我的教派的人的教堂？我能认出那是偏见。
It's hard for me to think that a patch up job in an ER that required sewing up sewing up versus fine-grained surgery that goes on for hours is really not going to have some substantial impact on the person's life. Maserid realized that a definition of discrimination is too narrow to capture this type of harm. We really measure prejudice in the old fashioned way by looking for acts of commission. What do I do? Do I go across a town to burn down the church of somebody who's not from my denomination? That I can recognize as prejudice.
但当我们不采取行动时，那是可以接受的。当有人受到更好的对待时，我们很少感到愤怒，这是可以理解的。我们看不到伤害，因为伤害是无形的。它是针对那些没有得到VIP待遇的人的。但这些人当时并不和卡拉在急诊室里。他们不知道自己错过了什么。如果你没有从中受益，你可能会怀疑偏爱正在剥夺你的机会，但通常很难准确指出你失去了什么。
But when we don't act, that's acceptable. It's understandable that we rarely feel outraged when someone gets treated better. We don't see the harm because the harm is invisible. It's directed at people who don't get the VIP treatment. But those people were not in the ER with Carla. They didn't know what they were missing. If you haven't benefited from this type of treatment, you might have suspicions that favoritism is costing you opportunities, but it's often hard to pinpoint what you're losing.
你不知道如果有人因为你们上了同一所大学而推荐你工作，会发生什么。或者如果你被邀请参加一个讨论公司重要业务的私人聚会，你的职业生涯会发生怎样的变化。对于马扎林来说，卡拉在医院描述的经历就像拉开了一道帷幕。卡拉突然明白了被当作普通人对待是什么感觉，以及被当作特殊人物对待是什么感觉。卡拉·卡普兰和卡普兰教授各自窥见了
You don't know what would have happened if someone had recommended you for a job because you both went to the same university. Or how your career would have changed if you had been invited to a private party were important company business god discussed. For Mazareen, the experience that Carla described in the hospital was like a curtain being pulled back. Carla suddenly got to see what it was like to be treated the same as everyone else and what it was like to be treated as someone special. Carla Kaplan and Professor Kaplan each got a glimpse of what
另一个人的生活是怎样的。这让马扎林反思了自己的行为。我度过一生时，根本不知道周围的人就是我正在帮助的人，除非我停下来问这个问题，我希望如何做到这一点？我打算帮助某一种人而不是另一种人吗？马扎林能想到一些她偏袒某些人的例子，因为他们和她有共同点。就像我写信请她就一个故事采访我的那次。
life was like for the other person. It made Mazarin reflect on her own behavior. I go through life having no clue that the people around me are the ones I'm helping, unless I pause and ask the question, how do I wish to do this? Do I intend to help one type of person over another? Mazarin can think of instances when she is favored people because they shared something in common with her. Like the time I write her ass to interview her for a story.
我通常会答应，但我问她是在为谁写作，当她告诉我时，我说，我想我不会做这个采访，因为我对她写作的杂志没有给予高度评价。我不认为它以非常有利的方式或作为一门科学呈现了心理学。我告诉了她。当她离开时，她在电话里说，
I typically oblige, but I asked her who she was writing for and when she told me, I said, I don't think, I'll do the interview because I did not hold the magazine she was writing for in high esteem. I didn't think it presented psychology in a terribly favorable way or as a science. And I told her that. And as she was departing, she said, on the phone,
她说，你还在那儿的时候，我曾是耶鲁的学生，尽管我没有上过你的课，但我确实记得听过你的工作。我脱口而出的下一句话是，好吧，过来吧，我和你谈谈。你知道，我那些不应该和一个不能准确代表我领域的杂志对话的高傲原则去哪儿了？
she said, I used to be a student at Yale when you were there and even though I didn't take a course with you, I do remember hearing about your work. And the next words out of my mouth were, OK, come on over, I'll talk to you. You know, what happened to my highfalutin principles that I ought not to talk to in magazine that does not represent my field accurately.
诸如此类。那一点点圈内信息，她和我共享了四年邮政编码的事实，就足以让我推翻自己的决定。这种行为当然是无处不在的。这就是为什么人们想去精英学校。不仅仅是为了教育，更是为了网络。我实际上认为这不仅非常普遍，
And so on. That little bit of in-group information, the fact that she and I had shared a zip code for four years was sufficient to make me override my decision. This type of behavior, of course, is pervasive. It's why people want to go to elite schools. It's not just for the education, it's for the network. I actually think that this is not only very much pervasive,
而且它经常出现在做一件好事的背景下。我们将这些偏见的行为解释为慷慨和善良的行为。卡拉的医生因为他们的共同渊源而对她感同身受，他竭尽全力去帮忙。他那天可能带着自豪的心情回家了。
but that it often appears in the context of doing something good. We interpret these acts of prejudice as acts of generosity and kindness. Carlos' doctor felt a connection to her because of their common affiliation, and he pulled out all the stops to help. He probably went home that day, feeling proud.
我认为这种对我们有某种共同群体认同的人的帮助行为，确实是歧视可能发生的现代方式。当然，偏袒并不是歧视发生的唯一方式。当前的新闻事件表明，其他形式的偏见依然存在。但偏袒却能在雷达下悄然潜行，尽管它有着严重的道德后果。我认为绝对是这样，在一个我们相信（我认为带着我们的善意）某些群体的人遭受苦难，或者可怕的事情发生时，那些是他们自己造成的的世界里。假设你听了这个故事，并决定不再偏心。
I think that kind of act of helping towards people with whom we have some shared group identity is really the modern way in which discrimination likely happens. Favouriteism, of course, is not the only way that discrimination happens. Current news events show us that other forms of prejudice are alive and well. But favoritism flies under the radar, despite having serious moral consequences. I think it absolutely does in a world in which we believe, I think, with our good intentions, that when certain groups of people suffer, or when terrible things happen to them, that those are of their own making. Let's say you listen to the story and decide you won't play favorites anymore.
那是令人钦佩的，但是……在生活的大多数情况下，要说“零水平、中立的行为在哪里？如果我这样做，我就没有歧视”，这并不容易。当我们回来时，如果我们对所有人都一视会是什么样子？老实说。是的，我会……我会牺牲他。请继续收听。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
That's admirable, but... It's not easy, in most cases in life, to say, where is that zero-level, neutral behavior? Where if I do that, I'm not discriminating. When we come back, what would it look like if we treated everyone the same? The honest. Yeah, I would... I would sacrifice him. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
偏袒是我们许多人以这样或那样的方式经历过的一种不引人注意的歧视形式。我们可能因为招聘经理上了同一所大学而获得了工作面试。我们可能因为有共同的朋友而帮了某人的忙。但有些人不仅能够注意到自己对偏袒的冲动，还能克服它。迪伦·马修斯就是其中之一。他走向这种道德立场的旅程有着不同寻常的起点。它始于讽刺和报复心，
Favourites is the unnoticed form of discrimination that many of us have experienced in one way or another. We may have gotten a job interview because the hiring manager went to the same university. We may have done a favor for someone because we have friends in common. But there are people who are not only able to notice their impulse toward favoritism, they're able to override it. Dylan Matthews is one of those people. His journey to this moral stance had unusual beginnings. It started with sarcasm and vindictiveness
以及当我发现这很有趣时想要惹恼某人。值得一提的是，迪伦当时还在读初中。我们社会学有一个学校项目，要求我们写一篇关于世界威胁的文章。正常人会写世界饥饿或艾滋病毒/艾滋病之类的内容。我朋友特蕾莎当时是个非常虔诚的天主教徒，她写了彼得·辛格的哲学，因为我想她曾听到她爸爸抱怨彼得·辛格和这个想要堕胎婴儿之类的家伙。
and wanting to annoy someone when I thought it was funny. It's probably worth noting that Dylan was in middle school at the time. We had this school project for social studies where we had to write about a threat to the world. And normal people would do like, world hunger or HIV-AIDS or something. And my friend Teresa, who then was a very devout Catholic, did the philosophy of Peter Singer, because I think she had heard her dad complaining about Peter Singer and this guy who wanted to abort infants or something.
彼得·辛格，迪伦的朋友鄙视的那位哲学家，就是我们在上一集中采访的那位哲学家。因为我当时12或13岁，是个混蛋，我出去买了一本彼得·辛格的书，并在她面前尽可能多地阅读。我发现其中大部分内容都很有说服力。所以我做的第一件事就是停止吃肉。但里面还有一篇题为《丰裕、道德与世界饥饿》的文章，写于1971年加莱战争的大背景下，其中提出富裕国家的人们有道德义务向贫困国家的人们捐款，而这样做并不会对他们的生活水平造成太大影响。如果你错过了上一集，彼得·辛格的哲学立场被称为功利主义。
Peter Singer, the philosopher that Dylan's friend despised was the same philosopher we spoke to in our last episode. And because I was 12 or 13 and a jerk, I went out and bought a Peter Singer book and would read it in front of her as much as I could. And I found much of it persuasive. So I stopped eating meat was the first thing I did. But there was also an essay in there called Femin Affluence and Morality, which was written during the the big Galley War in 1971 and was an argument that people in rich countries have a moral obligation to give to people in poor countries when doing that doesn't cost them much for their standard of living. If you missed our last episode, Peter Singer's philosophical position is known as Utilitarianism.
从本质上讲，它询问我们如何为最多的人增加最大程度的幸福和福祉。在一个著名的思想实验中，彼得让你想象在池塘边遇到一个溺水的儿童。假设拯救这个儿童意味着弄毁你身上穿的西装，费用是200美元。大多数人表示，他们宁愿拯救儿童也不愿保护他们的西装。
In essence, it asks how we can increase the greatest amount of happiness and well-being for the greatest number of people. In a famous thought experiment, Peter asks you to imagine coming by a drowning child in a pond. Let's say saving the child means ruining the suit you are wearing and it costs $200. Most people say they would rather save the child than save their suit.
如果真是这样，彼得说，为什么不给一个能够拯救地球另一端儿童生命的慈善组织开一张200美元的支票呢？这个比喻是：在那种情况下不捐款，就像你看到一个儿童在池塘里溺水，却因为不想弄脏西装而不跳进去一样。当迪伦第一次读到这个实验时，他还是个学生，没有收入可以捐款。当他终于开始工作并有了多余的钱时，池塘里溺水的儿童仍然留在他脑海的深处。带着这个想法，
If that's the case, Peter says, why not write a check for $200 to a charitable organization that can save a child's life on the other side of the planet? The analogy was not donating in those circumstances is like if you see a child drowning in a pond and you don't jump in because you don't want a dirty or suit. When Dylan first read the start experiment, he was still a student and didn't have income to donate. When he finally started working and had money to spare, the drowning child in the pond was still in the back of his mind. With that in the back of my
我想捐出一些钱，我偶然发现了一个名为“Givewell”的组织，该组织为那些希望在慈善捐赠中尽可能拯救最多生命的人推荐高效的慈善机构。他最终走上了有效 altruism 的道路，这是一个彼得·辛格协助启发的运动。有效 altruism 的目的是为他人做好事。这意味着使用证据和理性，而不是做感觉良好或直观上有吸引力的事情。鉴于他参与了这项运动，毫不奇怪，几年前，迪伦发现自己被一个像他一样认真对待伦理的人所吸引，一个
head I wanted to donate some of it and I happened upon a group called Givewell that recommended highly effective charities for people who wanted to sort of save as many lives as possible giving their charitable giving. He eventually found his way into effective altruism, a movement that Peter Singer helped to inspire. The aim of effective altruism is to do the most good possible for others. That means using evidence and reason rather than doing what feels good or is intuitively appealing. Given his involvement in this movement, it's not a surprise that several years ago, Dylan found himself attracted to someone who takes ethics as seriously as he does, someone who
对他人有一种责任感，愿意付出直到痛苦的人。我是汉娜·格劳奇-贝格利。令人惊讶的是，汉娜的道德框架与迪伦的有很大不同。我从小就被教育要真正去考虑你面前的那个人，去考虑你的家庭成员，去考虑你的朋友，去考虑我如何能把他们放在第一位，我如何能一直在他们身边，然后你知道，将其延伸到我们如何能让我们的社区更好，我们如何能让我们的城市更好。汉娜从父母日常生活中学习到了这些价值观。我的父母总是把晚饭时间放在首位，但是，你知道，无论他们的事业有多忙，
has a sense of duty to others who's willing to give until it hurts. I'm Hannah Grouch-Beglie. What is surprising is that Hannah's moral framework is very different from Dylan's. I was raised to really think about the person who's in front of you and to think about your family members, to think about your friends, and to think about how can I put them first, how can I always be there for them, and then you know extending that to how can we make our neighborhood better, how can we make our city better? Hannah learned these values from her parents as they went about their daily routines. My parents always prioritized dinner time, but, you know, no matter how busy they were
我们总是坐在一起，至少一起吃晚饭。迪伦和汉娜不同的道德框架在他们的第一次约会上就显现出来了。他们在华盛顿特区的一家酒吧见面。我记得这是一个问题，因为他们不提供食物，所以我们有点微醺。是的，我们喝了太多鸡尾酒，现在不得不把它们吸收掉。像第一次约会的所有情侣一样，他们调情了。当然，作为迪伦和汉娜，
with their careers, we always sat down and at least had dinner together. Dillon and Hannah's different moral frameworks became evident on their very first date. They met at a bar in Washington, DC. I remember it was a problem because they don't serve food and so we got a little tipsy. Yeah, we had too many cocktails and we now have to soak them up. Like all couples on a first date, they flurred. Of course, being Dillon and Hannah,
他们的调情采取了关于道德哲学的辩论形式。我们一直在争论，到底是仅仅在世界上最大化幸福更重要，还是不管你想最大化什么，你都应该最大化它，因此每一个行动都应该由此产生。迪伦认为不偏心是至关重要的。如果你想在世界上最大化幸福，你必须把每个人的幸福视为同样重要。一个人恰好住在你的街区还是你的家庭成员并不重要。他们的幸福不应该比世界另一端某人的幸福更重要。
their flirting took the form of a debate about moral philosophy. We were having this debate over, is it more important to just sort of maximize happiness in the world or whatever sort of thing you want to maximize, you should maximize it and therefore every action should follow from there. Dylan believed it was essential not to play favorites. If you want to maximize happiness in the world, you have to treat everyone's happiness as equally important. It doesn't matter whether someone happens to live on your block or is even a member of your family. Their happiness should not matter more than the happiness of someone who lives across the world.
我觉得这太疯狂、太离谱了。迪伦告诉汉娜，他刻意选择那些能够使最大多数人的福祉最大化的慈善机构。通常是男人向致力于帮助最穷的人的慈善机构捐款，例如，向提供蚊帐以预防疟疾的组织捐款。迪伦不向个人喜好的项目和事业捐款。我绝对不是那种思考者，而是更专注于我们如何拯救特定的社区或如何帮助某些群体。汉娜觉得很难理解你怎么能背弃邻居去帮助一个住在你从未见过的地方的人。他们意见的分歧本可以让他们分道扬镳。相反，它变成了一种充满活力的力量。
Which I thought was wild and insane. Dylan told Hannah he deliberately chose charities that could maximize the well-being of the greatest number of people. There's usually men giving to charities that work with the poorest of the poor, to organizations, for example, that provide bed nets to prevent malaria. Dylan did not donate to pet projects and causes. And I am very much not that kind of thinker and was much more focused on how do we save a particular community or how do we help certain groups of individuals. Hannah found it difficult to understand how you could turn your back on a neighbor
他们意见的分歧本可以让他们分道扬镳。相反，它变成了一种充满活力的力量。这正是最初火花的一部分，因为我们能够进行那些辩论。迪伦并没有期望汉娜重新校准她的道德指南针以匹配他的。汉娜也不认为迪伦会为她这样做。我们对彼此的热情、政治观点以及关于如何成为一个好人的愿望都有着极大的尊重，
to help someone who lives in a place you've never seen. The differences in their opinions could have driven them apart. Instead, it became an energizing force. The differences in their opinions could have driven them apart. Instead, it became an energizing force. That was sort of part of the original spark was that we were able to have those debates. Dylan did not expect Hannah to recalibrate her moral compass to match his. Nor did Hannah think Dylan would do that for her. We both have immense respect for each other's passions and political opinions and desires
有时我们对实现这一目标的最佳途径有分歧。但真正的考验出现在他们关系几个月后。我认为当事情变得更具体时，对我来说更困难了，那是在我们交往六个月后。迪伦决定把他的一个肾捐给一个陌生人。迪伦说，我想这样做，我想开始这个过程。他的逻辑很简单。
about how to be a good person in the world and sometimes we disagree about what the best path on that is. But the real test came a few months into their relationship. I think that it became more difficult for me when it became more concrete, which was six months into our relationship. Dylan had decided to donate one of his kidneys to a stranger. Dylan said, I want to do this, I want to start the process. His logic was straightforward.
有人正在死去，其中一个人需要一个肾，而这个将给其中一个人。所以当你在考虑这个时，你基本上是在说，我身体里有一个健康的器官，我想把它送给一个我不认识的人。是的。这难道不让你觉得这是一件很不寻常的事情吗？我理解这是一件很不寻常的事情，生活在这个世界上，并和那些觉得这是一件很不寻常的事情的人谈论过这一点。
There are people who are dying and one of them needs a kidney and this will go to one of them. So as you're thinking about this, you're basically saying, I have a functioning organ in my body that I want to give to somebody else who I don't know. Yeah. That does not strike you at all as being an unusual thing to say. I understand that it is an unusual thing to say, being in the world and having talked about this with people who find it to be an unusual thing to say.
但我不需要它。这是一个健康的器官，但它对我没用。在迪伦看来，不捐出他的肾就像囤积他永远不会吃的食物，而其他人却在挨饿。汉娜有不同的看法。有时我很害怕，我开始爱上的这个人可能会让自己陷入极大的危险之中。这是一个非常安全的手术，但我不是医生，所以你告诉我，哦，你要切除一个主要器官。选择性手术，我不明白你为什么要这样做。
But I didn't need it. It's a functioning organ, but I wasn't doing anything for me. To Dylan, not giving away his kidney was like hoarding food he'd never eat while others were hungry. Hannah saw it differently. There were moments when I was very scared that this person who I was starting to love was going to potentially put themselves in a great deal of danger. It is a very safe procedure, but I'm not a doctor, so you tell me, oh, you're gonna remove a major organ. Elective surgery, I don't understand why you would do that.
如果迪伦的父亲需要一个肾而迪伦恰好匹配，汉娜可能不会那么纠结。但为了一个陌生人切除一个主要器官？对我来说非常清楚，这是不可协商的，这是会发生的。我认为问题是，我会在那里支持吗？迪伦继续进行了手术，汉娜在那里陪着他。手术本身花了将近四个小时，那只是我生命中的四个小时，
Hannah would have struggled less if Dylan's father needed a kidney and Dylan was a match. But having a major organ extracted for a stranger? It was very clear to me that this was non-negotiable, that this was gonna happen. I think the question was, am I gonna be here for that? Dylan went ahead with the surgery, and Hannah was there for him. The surgery itself took almost four hours, and that was just four hours in my life
我根本不知道迪伦是否安好。那天晚上她几乎没睡，她确保迪伦有专人全天候为他的需求发声。恢复的前几天很艰难。迪伦的经历被新闻网站 Vox 记录了下来。他是那里的专职作家。很好，我很好。我到目前为止只吐了一次。所以就是这样，他们有一堆必须做的练习
that I had no idea whether or not Dylan was okay or not. She got little sleep that night as she made sure Dylan had someone advocating for his needs around the clock. The first few days of recovery were rough. Dylan's experience was recorded by the new site, Vox. He's a staff writer there. Good, I'm good. I've only thrown up once so far. So there's that and they have a bunch of exercises they
在视频中，迪伦吹着一个塑料管。手术两周后又回去工作了。仍然相当痛苦，但不是超级痛苦。手术两周后迪伦又回去工作了。他在 Vox 上写了一篇文章，标题是《为什么我把肾捐给陌生人，以及为什么你也应该考虑这样做》。他的文章和视频帮助宣传了这种不同寻常的利他主义。一些读者告诉他，他们因为他的文章而受到启发去捐献一个肾。他在一个为肾脏捐赠者举行的仪式上受到了表彰。
have to do. In the video, Dylan blows into a plastic tube. And went back to work two weeks after the surgery. He Still pretty painful, but not super painful. Dylan went back to work two weeks after the surgery. He wrote an article for Vox with a title, Why I gave my kidney to a stranger and why you should consider doing it too. His article and the video helped publicize this unusual form of altruism. Some readers told him that they were inspired to donate a kidney because of his peace. He was honored at a ceremony for kidney donors.
那天晚上他收到的奖杯放在迪伦和汉娜客厅的书架上。这是一个非常沉重的金属砖，上面写着“美国英雄迪伦·马修斯”。我当时一点也不觉得尴尬。它来自国家肾脏登记处，他们把这个送给迪伦真是太好了。它很漂亮，很沉。这是我一生中见过的最好的摆设之一。迪伦和汉娜的分歧很迷人，
The award he received that night sits on a bookshelf in Dylan and Hannah's living room. It is this very heavy metal brick that says American hero hero Dylan Matthews. I did not find that embarrassing at all then. It's from the National Kidney Registry and it was very kind of them to give it to Dylan. It's pretty it's hefty. It's one of the better opalists I've ever seen in my life. Dylan and Hannah's differences are fascinating,
因为他们都有对道德人是什么的完全引人注目的愿景。这些愿景相互冲突。我很好奇他们是如何看待一个被称为“电车难题”的著名道德困境的。你可能以前听过，如果没有，这里有一个对这个问题进行了广泛研究的人的总结。
because they both have entirely compelling visions of what it is to be a moral person. These visions clash with one another. I was curious how they think about a famous moral dilemma known as a trolley problem. You've probably heard it before, but if not, here's a summary from someone who has studied the problem extensively.
我是约书亚·格林。我是哈佛大学心理学系的教授，我研究道德决策和高级认知。约书亚说，电车难题已经达到了传奇的地位。电车难题已经成为了一种模因。以至于它甚至出现在了全国电视上。
I'm Joshua Green. I'm a professor in the psychology department at Harvard University, and I study moral decision-making and high-level cognition. Joshua says the trolley problem has achieved the status of legend. The trolley problem has become a kind of beam. So much so, it's even featured on Network TV.
它在电视剧《善地》中出现过，该剧探讨了道德哲学的问题。哦天哪，迈克尔，你做了什么？我让电车难题变为了现实，这样我们就能看到伦理学将如何实际发挥作用。这条轨道上有五个工人，那边有一个。这里是转换轨道的杠杆。做一个选择。这是它的经典版本。一辆电车或火车正沿着轨道飞驰。它的刹车坏了，无法停下来。
It's on the show The Good Place, which explores questions and moral philosophy. Oh God, Michael, what did you do? I made the trolley problem real so we could see how the ethics would actually play out. There are five workers on this track and one over there. Here in the levers to switch the tracks. Take a choice. This is the classic version of it. A trolley or a train is hottling down a track. Its brakes are shot and it cannot be stopped.
电车正驶向五个人，但你可以按下开关，把它转向一条只撞死一个人的支路。问题是，按下开关以尽量减少生命损失可以吗？为了拯救五个无辜者的生命而杀死一个无辜的人可以吗？许多人觉得这个道德困境令人痛苦，但会告诉你，是的，如果拯救五个人意味着无意中杀死一个人，那么这样做是正确的。但有一种方法可以使这个困境不仅艰难，而且极其痛苦。
The trolley is headed towards five people, but you can hit a switch that will turn it onto a sidetrack where only kill one person. And the question is, is it okay to hit the switch to minimize the loss of life? Is it okay to kill one innocent person to save the lives of five innocent people? Many people find the moral dilemma painful, but will tell you, yes, if saving five people means unintentionally killing one, then it's the right thing to do. But there's a way to make the dilemma not just hard, but excruciating.
如果你不得不牺牲生命的那个人是你认识的人，你爱的人呢？你爱的人。我曾开玩笑说，我想如果你处于那种可怕的境地，你知道，这辆电车轨道上的五个人即将被杀死，而拯救他们的唯一方法就是杀死你自己的孩子，迪伦会为了拯救那五个人而杀死他自己的孩子。因为他对待道德有一种非常（我认为）理性的方法，孩子是一条生命。
What if the one person whose life you have to sacrifice is someone you know, someone you love? someone you love. I have joked that I think if you were in the horrible situation in which, you know, the five people who are on this trolley track are about to be killed, and the only way to save them is to kill your own child, that Dylan would kill his own child in order to save those five people. Because he has this very, I think, rational approach to morality, the child is one life.
五个人的生命比那个孩子更重要。我会救那个孩子。为了我自己的孩子，我会毫不犹豫地杀死五个人。我知道这一点，而且我不是母亲。我只是知道我就是那种母亲。我会杀死那个……是的，我甚至都不会质疑。就像，五对一。我可能会在悲伤之后自杀，所以会是五对二。但是，是的，不，这对我来说不是一个难题。
Five people's lives are more than that one child. I would save the child. I would easily kill five people on behalf of my own child. I know that, and I'm not a mother. I just know that that's the kind of mother I would be. I would kill the chick. Yeah, I wouldn't even question it. Like, it's five against one. I would probably kill myself after out of grief and so it would be five against two. But yeah, no, that's not a hard problem for me.
就像，那些人都是他们自己故事中的英雄，他们都有像我爱这个孩子一样爱他们的挚爱。在我看来，把我的依恋置于他们生活中依恋之上是极其下流的。是的，我对钢琴有完全不同的直觉。我忍不住请他们俩考虑一个更贴近现实的场景。这仍然是假设的，但鉴于你现在实际上还没有孩子，它不那么假设一点。假设一条轨道上有五个人，另一条轨道上有汉娜。你会怎么做？说实话。
Like, those people are all the heroes of their own stories and they all have loved ones who love them as much as I love the kid. And it seems obscene to me to treat my attachment as paramount of their attachments in their lives. Yeah, I just have totally different intuitions about that from a piano. I couldn't resist asking the two of them to consider a scenario that's even closer to home. This is still hypothetical, but it's a little less hypothetical given that you don't actually have a kid right now. Let's say it was five people in one track and it was Hannah on the other track. What would you do? Be honest.
是的，我会，我会牺牲汉娜。我非常爱汉娜。事后我会和她的父母进行很多非常紧张的对话。我认为约翰和瓦尔不会在我的生活中待太久了。现在我把同样的假设抛给你。所以假设是五个，另一条轨道上不是一个孩子，而是迪伦。你会怎么做？嗯，我可能会杀了迪伦，因为我
Yeah, I would, I would sacrifice Hannah. I love Hannah very much. I would have a lot of very tense conversations with their parents afterwards. I don't think John and Val would be in my life for much longer. Let me pose the same hypothetical to you now. So let's say it was five and it's not a child on the other track, but it was Dylan on the other track. What would you do? Well, I might kill Dylan because I would
知道那是他想要的。我永远不会原谅你。是的，如果我杀了几个人而他还活着，他会对我非常生气。所以我想我想我会牺牲他，但我认为这会很艰难。我认为在电光石火的瞬间我会选择拯救，因为我认为，你知道，我的本能是保护我所爱的人。我把迪伦和汉娜的事告诉了约书亚·格林。他注意到了他们对思想实验反应中一些揭示性的东西。她仍然承认他会做的事情在某种意义上是理性的，那是她用的词，对吧？
know that's what he wanted. I would never forgive you. Yeah, if I killed five people and he was alive, he'd be very mad at me. So I think I think I would sacrifice him, but I think it would be hard. I think a split second decision I would save, because I think, you know, my instinct is to protect my loved ones. I told Joshua Green about Dylan and Hannah. He noticed something revealing about their responses to the thought experiment. She's still acknowledged that what he would do is rational, in a sense, that's the word she used, right?
并不是她不理解。只是她不明白这怎么能比那些基本的普遍人类和哺乳动物的情感获得更大的分量。他说，是的，我可能会牺牲我的孩子，然后我会因为痛苦而自杀。所以并不是说他感觉不到。而是他愿意克服它，他在那个假设中担心他可能在当下克服了它，但无法在余生中克服它，在这种情况下，他宁愿结束自己的生命，所以我想实际上
It wasn't that she didn't understand it. It's just that she didn't understand how that could get more weight than those basic human and mammalian feelings. And he said, yeah, I would probably sacrifice my child and then I would kill myself out of anguish So it's not that he doesn't feel it. It's that he's willing to override it And he worries in that hypothetical that he could maybe override it in the moment But couldn't override it for the rest of his life in which case he'd rather end his life so I think there's actually
存在一些相互理解，尽管最终，天平对其中一个人倾向于一边，而对另一个人倾向于另一边。当我们回来时，这些不同的道德框架如何在脑海中体现。请继续收听。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。偏袒在我们心中根深蒂固。我们大多数人不会质疑我们偏爱核心圈子的冲动，因为我们将这种行为视为善良和慷慨。
There is some mutual understanding there despite the fact that in the end, the balance tips one way for one of them and the other way for the other. When we come back, how these different moral frameworks are reflected inside the brain. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Favouritism is deeply ingrained in us. Most of us don't question our impulse to favor our inner circle because we view such behavior as kind and generous.
我们相信这种行为使我们成为一个好朋友或值得信赖的伙伴。但有些人，比如迪伦·迪伦·马修斯，对待他们认识的人和陌生人有着同样的承诺和关怀。我非常钦佩迪伦愿意为一个陌生人放弃他的肾，但我不会那样做。再次是心理学家约书亚·格林。约书亚知道，虽然我们许多人可能钦佩迪伦，但我们大多数人像汉娜一样，倾向于偏爱我们认识的人。我们并不感到在道德上有义务帮助陌生人，就像我们会帮助我们爱的人那样。我们的整个社会都建立在一个理念周围，即
We believe such acts make us a good friend or a trusted partner. But some people, like Dylan Matthews, treat those they know and strangers with the same commitment and care. I admire Dylan greatly for his willingness to give up his kidney for a stranger, but I wouldn't do that. This again is psychologist Joshua Green. Joshua knows that while many of us may admire Dylan, most of us, like Hannah, tend to favor those we know. We don't feel morally compelled to help strangers, in the same way we'd help someone we love. And our whole society is structured around the idea
我们的生活是由这些情感持久且有意义的个人关系所定义的。这背后有进化的原因。几千年来，偏爱亲近之人的古代人类具有优势。他们能够合作，这种合作使他们能够在竞争中胜过他人。道德从根本上讲是关于合作的。它是一套心理能力，使我们能够合作进行团队合作，对吧？所以，你知道，基本的规则比如不要撒谎，不要作弊，不要偷窃，那些是使人们能够生活在一起的规则。
that our lives are defined by these emotionally durable and meaningful personal relationships. There's an evolutionary reason for this. Over thousands of years, humans who favored those close to them had an advantage. They could cooperate and such cooperation allowed them to outcompete others. Morality is fundamentally about cooperation. It's a suite of psychological capacities that enable us to cooperate to have teamwork, right? And so, you know, basic rules like don't lie, don't cheat, don't steal, those are rules that make it possible for people to live together.
无论是在村庄里还是在家庭中。最基本的合作形式是有血缘关系的个体之间的合作。真正发生的是，存在于你们两个身体里的基因本质上是在说：这里和那里有相同的基因，你们应该把对方当作同类对待，或者至少不要太不同。你知道，那些编码关心那些与你共享基因并因此拥有该基因副本的个体基因，这些基因更有可能传播，
Whether in a village or a family. The most basic form of cooperation is cooperation between individuals who are genetically related. And what's really going on there is that the gene that is in both of your bodies is essentially saying same gene here and there, you should be treating each other as a like, or at least not as too different. You know, genes that encode for caring about the individuals who share your genes and therefore have a copy of that gene, those genes are more likely to spread,
无论是在村庄里还是在家庭中，最基本的合作形式是具有基因关联的个体之间的合作。这里真正发生的情况是，在你我身体中的基因本质上是在说，这里和那里都有相同的基因，你们应该像对待同类一样对待彼此，或者至少不要对待得太有差异。你知道，那些促使人们关心与自己共享基因、因而也拥有该基因副本的个体的基因，这些基因更有可能传播开来，
right? So the most basic kind of cooperation is cooperation based on genetic relatedness and then the next level up is based on the kind of reciprocity in a direct face-to-face sort of way. So this is you know friends you share food with each other You'd have each other's backs when going into battle take care of each other's children take care of each other or you know When you're sick that's what friends are for right and Everybody is likely to do better if they have other people that they can cooperate with. You can imagine the circle of cooperation, expanding even further. You get out to different levels where there might be people
对吧？所以最基础的合作是基于基因关联的合作，然后下一个层级是基于一种面对面的互惠方式。所以这就是，你知道的，朋友之间分享食物，上战场时互相照应，照顾彼此的孩子，或者你知道的，生病时互相照顾，这就是朋友的意义，对吧？而且如果人们有可以合作的对象，每个人都可能会过得更好。你可以想象合作的圈子还在进一步扩大。你会扩展到不同的层级，那里可能有些人
who you don't know personally, but you have some kind of connection with. That is you're a member of the same religion or you're a member of the same country or you have some other kinds of shared connections or interests, or you're a friend of my friend, or a friend of a friend of my friend, right? Then, you know, those are more symbolically marked. It's not based on your experience with that person, but what you have encoded about them in a more abstract kind of way.
你并不认识，但你们之间某种程度上有所联系。也就是说，你是同一宗教的成员，或者是同一国家的成员，或者你们有其他某种共同的联系或兴趣，或者你是我的朋友的朋友，或者是我朋友的朋友的朋友，对吧？然后，你知道的，这些都是带有象征意义的标记。它不是基于你与那个人的经历，而是基于你以一种更抽象的方式对他们进行的编码。
There's a simple image you can use to picture this. As the philosopher Peter Singer put it, we live in these moral concentric circles. If you're a complete narcissist, it's just you at the middle, right? And then when we ring out as your family and your closest friends and then people who you're more acquainted with, people who are in a, you know, perhaps part of your town, your village, and then broader connections with people, even people who are strangers, but are connected to you in some way. And so in some sense, the most basic question
你可以用一个简单的意象来描绘这一点。正如哲学家彼得·辛格所说，我们生活在这些道德同心圆中。如果你是一个十足的自恋狂，中心就只有你，对吧？然后向外扩展，是你的家人和最亲密的朋友，然后是更熟悉的人，比如可能处于你的城镇、村庄里的人，再然后是与更广泛人群的联系，甚至是那些与你素不相识、但以某种方式与你相连的人。所以在某种意义上，最基本的问题
that anyone has to answer is, how big is my us? What is the range of humans or beings even that I care about? Dylan's circle of Care is very large. It's basically the entire world. Hannah's Circle is much smaller. It's her family, her community, her city. Few of us operate solely with either of these frameworks. We move back and forth. Joshua compares these different moral frameworks to settings on a camera.
每个人都必须回答的是：我的“我们”有多大？我关心的或者是人类或生命的范围有多广？迪伦的关怀圈非常大。它基本上涵盖了整个世界。汉娜的圈子要小得多。它涵盖了她的家人、她的社区、她的城市。我们当中很少有人仅仅依靠这两种框架中的某一种来行事。我们在它们之间来回切换。约书亚将这些不同的道德框架比作相机上的设置。
Think about photography, especially if you're kind of a weak amateur photographer like me. So the camera that I've used for years has these nice automatic settings. So if I want to take a picture of a mountain from a mile away, then I put it in landscape setting and click, point and shoot, and I've got a pretty good picture of a mountain from far away, or it has portrait mode and dark mode, et cetera, right? And the idea is that the manufacturer has thought into advance, you know, what are the kinds of things
想想摄影，特别是如果你像我一样是个水平不高的业余摄影师的话。我用了多年的那台相机有这些很棒的自动设置。所以，如果我想拍一张一英里外的山景照片，我就会把它调到风景模式，然后点击、对焦并按下快门，就能拍出一张相当不错的远山照片；或者它有肖像模式和暗光模式等等，对吧？这个想法是，制造商已经提前为你考虑过了，你知道，有哪些类型的事情
that people need to do all the time? We're just gonna set up these pre-programmed responses for those things, and that's what people use most of the time, and that's what I do. Occasionally, I get ambitious and will want to do something fancy and maybe have something slightly out of focus and off to the side and who knows, right? And so there you put the camera in manual mode, and that allows you to adjust the F-stop and everything else by hand.
人们会一直需要去做？我们只要为这些事情设置这些预编程的响应，人们大部分时间都在使用这些，我也是这么做的。偶尔我会雄心勃勃，想要做一些花哨的事情，也许想让画面稍微失焦、偏向一侧，谁知道呢，对吧？所以这时候你把相机调到手动模式，这就能让你手动调整光圈以及其他所有参数。
There are benefits to having both of these camera modes. It allows you to navigate the trade-off between efficiency and flexibility or reliability and an inflexibility. That is, if I try to do all those different things that I might do for portraits and landscapes, by hand, I might make a mistake and I'm trying to do this quickly. It's much better to have a point and shoot setting. But you can't do everything you might want to do with point in shoot settings, and that's why the manual mode is great. And in the same way, we humans have gut reactions, we have feelings, we have habits. In a familiar kind of situation, you don't even have to think or reason about it when it's
拥有这两种相机模式都有好处。它能让你在效率与灵活性，或者可靠性与不灵活性之间权衡。也就是说，如果我试图用手动来完成所有那些我可能在拍摄人像和风景时会做的事情，我可能会犯错，而且我是在赶时间。有一个“傻瓜”拍摄设置要好得多。但你不可能用“傻瓜”设置做到你想做的所有事情，这就是手动模式如此棒的原因。同样地，我们人类也有本能反应、情感和习惯。在一种熟悉的情境下，你甚至不需要去思考或推理，当这是一件
something that's just obviously a terrible thing to do. And that's good. You want to have that kind of efficiency and sturdiness in your everyday basic moral judgment. But then, sometimes life is complicated, and sometimes there are difficult trade-offs, and then that's when you wanna shift into manual mode. Joshua finds this analogy helpful because it answers a question that people tend to ask,
显然极其糟糕的事情时。这很好。你希望在日常基础道德判断中拥有这种效率和稳健性。但是，有时候生活很复杂，有时存在艰难的权衡，这时候你就需要切换到手动模式。约书亚觉得这个类比很有用，因为它回答了人们倾向于问的一个问题，
which moral framework is better? And the answer is neither is better. It depends on what you're trying to do. If you're trying to do something quickly, fast, and fairly routine, then you want the automatic settings. And if you're trying to do something more complicated and you're out of your usual element or trying to do something new, then you want the manual mode. And I think it's the same thing with moral thinking that when it comes to the ethics of everyday life, the basic things that everybody should
哪种道德框架更好？答案是：没有哪个更好。这取决于你想要做什么。如果你想快速、敏捷且相当常规地完成某件事，那么你需要自动设置。如果你想做更复杂的事情，超出了你通常的舒适区，或者想尝试新的事物，那么你需要手动模式。我认为道德思考也是如此，当涉及到日常生活伦理时，也就是每个人都应该
know not to do, the lying, stealing, cheating kinds of things, we want to have automatic settings that just say, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, can't do that. But then when we're making difficult decisions, decisions where on the one hand something might feel wrong or break some kind of rule, but on the other hand, it could mean more people will die if you do the thing that seems like the ordinarily right thing to do. Then you want to be able to weigh those things against each other and that is exactly what our brains do. Joshua and other researchers have found that different parts of the brain are at work when by using our manual mode and our automatic mode.
知道不该去做的基本事情，比如撒谎、偷窃、作弊这类事，我们希望有自动设置，直接说：不，不，不，不，不，不能做那种事。但当我们做出艰难的决定时——有些决定一方面可能让人觉得不对劲或打破了某种规则，但另一方面，如果你不做这件通常看起来正确的事，就意味着更多的人会死去——这时你就需要能够权衡这些事情，而这正是我们的大脑所做的事情。约书亚和其他研究人员发现，当我们使用手动模式和自动模式时，大脑的不同部分正在发挥作用。
When people are specifically engaging the utilitarian reasoning you see increased activity in a part of the brain called the dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex. It's part of a network in our brain that's the home of hard thinking and self-control. Like if you're trying to remember a long string of numbers or something like that or if you're trying to remember a long string of numbers or something like that, or if you're resisting an impulse. The automatic mode engages a different part of the brain. Part of the brain called the amygdala, which is a kind of early warning, attention directing system that says something's going on here, maybe bad, you've got to pay attention to this. And so if you see a snake, for example, before you even realize what you've seen at a sort of conceptual level, your brain is already responding with that flash of, whoa, something, something you need to pay attention to there.
当人们专门参与功利主义推理时，你会看到大脑中一个被称为背外侧前额叶皮层的区域活动增加。它是我们大脑中负责深度思考和自我控制的网络的一部分。就像如果你试图记住一串长数字或类似的事情，或者如果你在压抑一种冲动。自动模式会激活大脑的不同部分。大脑中被称为杏仁核的部分，它是一种早期预警、注意力导向系统，它在说：这里有点情况，可能不太妙，你得注意这个。因此，举个例子，如果你看到一条蛇，甚至在你从某种概念层面上意识到自己看到了什么之前，你的大脑就已经用那种闪电般的反应做出回应了：哇，有情况，你需要注意那里。
Joshua has used dilemmas like the trolley problem to understand what happens when we shift between the two modes. The most revealing scenarios hit the two modes against one another. One of these scenarios, the dilemma of the crying baby. This is kind of a horrible case. And I think when I first started thinking about this, it was before I had kids, and now that I have kids, it's like even more horrible to think about. But this is modeled after some stories that people told about what happened in World War II.
约书亚曾用诸如“电车难题”之类的困境来理解我们在两种模式之间切换时会发生什么。最具启示性的场景是将这两种模式相互对立起来。其中一个场景是“哭泣的婴儿”困境。这是一种相当可怕的情况。我想我刚开始思考这个问题时，我还没有孩子，而现在我有了孩子，再想这件事就觉得更加可怕了。但这是根据人们讲述的关于二战期间发生的事情的一些故事模仿而来的。
And the other story is that people are hiding in a basement and the enemy soldiers are outside. And there's a baby that starts to cry. And if the soldiers hear the baby, they'll find everybody and they'll kill everybody, including the baby, is it morally acceptable to smother the baby in order to save everybody else, knowing that the baby would die anyway if you didn't do anything.
另一个故事是，人们躲在地下室里，敌方士兵就在外面。有个婴儿开始哭泣。如果士兵听到婴儿的哭泣，他们就会找到所有人并杀死所有人，包括婴儿，为了拯救其他人而将婴儿闷死，在明知如果不采取行动婴儿无论如何都会死的情况下，这样做在道德上是可以接受的吗？
Compared to the standard version of the Charlie problem, the crying baby case ramps up the stakes. One, it's your own child, as opposed to a stranger, and at least the way the story is described, the child's going to die anyway if you don't do that. And so that's something that also seems to matter. That is, in general, people are more willing to say that it's okay to do the horrible thing in the name of the greater good if the horrible thing involves hurting somebody who would end up being harmed anyway.
与标准版的电车难题相比，“哭泣的婴儿”案例提高了赌注。第一，这是你自己的孩子，而不是陌生人；第二，至少按照故事的描述，如果你不这样做，孩子无论如何都会死。所以这也是一个似乎很重要的因素。也就是说，总的来说，如果可怕的事情涉及伤害一个无论如何最终都会受到伤害的人，人们会更愿意为了更大的利益而认为做这件可怕的事是可以接受的。
If you give people brain scans as they consider such dilemmas, you can almost see different parts of their minds wrestle with something that feels viscerally wrong but logically correct. When people have to make and all things considered judgment where they are not told to just think about your feelings or just think about the consequences, but instead try to weigh those things against each other, you see increased activity in a part of the brain called the adventure medial prefrontal cortex. This part of the brain integrates these two different types of decision-making.
如果你在人们考虑此类困境时对他们进行脑部扫描，你几乎可以看到他们大脑的不同部分在进行一场搏斗：一边是本能上觉得不对劲但逻辑上正确的东西。当人们必须做出综合考量的判断时——没有人告诉他们只要去想自己的感受或者只要去想后果，而是试图去权衡这些事情——你会看到大脑中一个被称为腹内侧前额叶皮层的区域活动增加。大脑的这一部分整合了这两种不同类型的决策。
It's like these different weights get added up and the scale tips one way or another and that's how we decide what to do. We told you a second ago that one system for moral reasoning is not better than the other. That's true, but not always. There are situations in our modern world for which the fast, intuitive system in our heads is not well designed. This system was not designed for a world
就像这些不同的重量被加在一起，天平向这样或那样倾斜，这就是我们决定该怎么做的方式。我们刚才告诉过你，一种道德推理系统并不比另一种更好。这确实如此，但并非总是如此。在我们现代世界中，有些情况下，我们头脑中快速、直观的系统并不是为此而设计的。这个系统不是为这样一个世界设计的：
in which we no longer live in tribes where the people who live near us don't always look like us. They were not designed for a time when we're capable of helping people on the other side of the world. When Dylan thinks about the balance between these modes of moral reasoning,
在这个世界里，我们不再生活在部落中，住在我们附近的人并不总是长得和我们一样。它们不是为这样一个时代设计的：在这个时代，我们有能力帮助世界另一端的人。当迪伦思考这些道德推理模式之间的平衡时，
his mind jumps to cases where loyalty and love cause real harm. One example, he says, are the ways in which some men have responded to concerns about sexual misconduct. There have been a lot of stories of the nature of, hey, I'm a guy in media or politics or entertainment. I've heard rumors about this guy friend of mine
他的脑海里立刻浮现出忠诚和爱造成真正伤害的案例。他说，其中一个例子是某些男性对性骚扰担忧的回应方式。有许多类似性质的故事，比如：“嘿，我是个混迹于媒体、政治或娱乐圈的家伙。过去几年里，我听说过我这个男性朋友对女性态度恶劣的传言。”“我什么都不会说，因为我觉得他是个好人，他值得我为他挺身而出并卷入他的私事。”这关乎很多事情。这关乎根深蒂固的厌女症、压抑和问责制，但我认为这也关乎男性将忠诚置于其他美德之上。
being awful toward women for the last few years. I'm not going to say anything because I feel like he's a good guy and he deserves better than for me to stick my neck out and get into his business. That's about a lot of things. That's about endemic misogyny and depression and accountability, but I think it's also about men placing loyalty before other virtues.
在家庭环境中，我有一些这样的经历：人们的行为表现得好像“我们是一家人并且彼此忠诚”意味着他们可以逃脱任何惩罚，没有人会评判他们，因为他们是一家人，无论如何我们都团结在一起。我认为在这些情况下，我的态度以及我身边人的态度是：不，你不能那样做。这是有底线的，我们不会无论如何都盲目坚持。我认为所有这些局部的偏私加起来，
And in a family context, I've had some experience of people acting like the fact that we are family and loyal to each other means they can get away with anything and that no one will judge them because they're family and we stick together no matter what. And I think in those cases, my attitude and the attitude of people close to me is, no, you don't get to do that. That there are limits and we're not going to stick by no matter what. I think the sum total of all of our small partialities
在很多情况下导致了许多不公正。这并不意味着这种忠诚总是对的，比如你应该对人们保持忠诚。这是值得忠诚的，但我认为“值得忠诚”这一点有时未经审视。即使是我们这些认识到偏袒问题的人，也可能会发现真正采取行动实在是太难了。突然之间，我们必须对每一个决定负责。如果我们在孩子的生日派对上花200美元，我们就等于选择不把这200美元用来拯救远方国家的一个贫穷儿童。我们必须正视这意味着什么。那个遥远孩子的生命，其分量不如
has added up to a lot of injustices in a lot of cases. That doesn't mean loyalties of that thing always like You should be loyal to people. It's worth being loyal to but I think the The worth being loyal to part is sometimes unexamined Even those of us who recognize the problem with favoritism may find that actually doing something about it is simply too hard Suddenly we have to account for every decision. If we spend $200 on our child's birthday party, we've chosen not to spend that $200 saving a poor child in a faraway country. We have to reckon with what this means. The life of that far away child matters less
住在我们家里的这个孩子的快乐重要。当世界上还有那么多贫困时，把钱花在家人、朋友或我们自己身上可能会让人觉得是一种奢侈。迪伦赞同把别人的需求放在首位有时也可能做得过火。他认为给予他人必须是可持续的。我做出过这样的判断：我不会因为把自己收入的10%而不是
than the happiness of the one who lives in our house. Spending money on family or friends or ourselves can feel like extravagances when there's so much deprivation in the world. Dylan agrees that you can go too far in putting other people's needs first. He believes that giving to others needs to be sustainable. I've made the judgment that I'm not going to beat myself up for giving 10% rather than
50%捐出去而责备自己。汉娜对此也有话要说，而且不仅限于他们如何捐款。嗯，我想肝脏就是一个例子。对，就是记住……你想捐一个肝？对，……肝脏？对，肝脏可太大了。
50% of my income. Hannah also has a say in this, and not just when it comes to how they give away money. Well, I guess the liver is one example. Yeah, it's remembering the... You wanted to donate a liver? Yeah, the... The liver? Yeah, the liver is a lot.
你来跟我们说说肝脏。你不需要肝脏，所以……他不需要肝脏。所以，在迪伦捐赠了肾脏之后，我们被邀请去纽约参加一个非常棒的盛会，那是个旨在表彰肾脏捐献者的活动。这就是迪伦获得他书架上那个写着“美国英雄”奖杯的同一个盛会。
You tell us the liver. You don't have to liver, so... He does not have to liver. So, after Dylan donated his kidney, we were invited to this very nice gala in New York that sort of celebrates kidney donors. This is the same gala where Dylan was given the award that's on his bookshelf, the one that says American Hero.
我们被安排坐在一张桌子旁，同桌的还有大约四五位其他肾脏捐献者及其配偶，几乎所有人都是男性。这些家伙开始聊天，他们谈到既然已经捐了肾，现在他们正在考虑的是捐肝。其中有一个家伙特别起劲，他说：“我只切一小部分，这是为了一个婴儿。”是的，如果你把肝脏捐给一个孩子，你不需要捐献整个器官，你只需要捐出一小部分，
We were sat at this table with maybe like four or five other kidney donors and their spouses, almost all of whom were men. The guys start talking and they start talking about how now that they've donated the kidney, what they're thinking about is donating the liver. There's one guy in particular who's like, I'm just gonna do a small piece, so it's for a baby. Yeah, that if you donate liver to a child, you don't have to donate the entire organ, you just have to donate a little piece of it
因为它会生长。然后你还可以多次这样做，因为你自己的肝脏会重新长出来，接着你就可以从上面切一小块下来捐出去。然后这些家伙都觉得：“太棒了，听起来真不错。我一直在考虑这个。”
because it will grow. And so then also you can do this multiple times because your own liver will grow back and then you could cut a little piece off of it and donate that. And the guys are all like, yeah, that sounds great. I've been thinking about this.
这太神奇了。感觉就像滑板爱好者，就像跟一个正尝试着他们从未尝试过的新动作的人聊天一样。我们当时想：“太酷了，老兄。”而所有的配偶们的反应则是：“绝对不行。我拒绝再经历一次。”[♪ 背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，将器官捐献给陌生人。我称之为深度实用主义。他将自己的方法比作节食。
It's amazing. It felt like skateboarders, like talking to someone who's trying to new trick they had never tried before. We're like, that's sweet, man. And all of the spouses are like, absolutely not. I refuse to do this again. [♪ Music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing organs to strangers. What I call deep pragmatism. He compares his approach to dieting.
你可以想象一下你生理上最理想的饮食，但如果你根本坚持不下去，那这就不是最适合你的饮食，对吧？最适合你的饮食是你最有可能坚持下去的那种饮食。我认为做一个有道德的人也是如此，尽管这是一个比节食严重得多的问题，但道理是一样的，这就是深度实用主义者的视角，即要记住你是在自己心理的极限范围内
You can imagine you're physiologically optimal diet, but that's not the best diet for you if you're never going to stick to it, right? The best diet for you is the diet that you're most likely to stick with. I think of being a moral person, even though it's a much more serious issue than dieting, it's the same, that's the deep pragmatist perspective, is to remember that you're operating
行事的。要关心核心圈子以外的人需要什么？它要求我们问出约书亚之前提出过的问题。我的“我们”有多大？我关心的或者是人类或生命的范围有多广？我们有能力扩大属于我们“我们”的人的范围。心理学家马泽琳·巴纳吉（Maserin Banaji）就亲身经历过这一点。在日本发生海啸期间，
within the limits of your own psychology. What does it take to care for people beyond those in our inner circle? It requires us to ask the same question that Joshua raised earlier. How big is my us? What is the range of humans or beings even that I care about? We're capable of expanding the range of people who fit in our us. Maserin Banaji, the psychologist, has experienced this herself. During the tsunami that hit Japan,
我花了两秒钟就给我日本的同事写信，因为我认识一个住在那里、曾在研究生院陪我度过一段时光的人。我立即给红十字会开了一张支票，所有这些行动都发生了。而这发生在世界的某个陌生角落，在我的祖父母和父母的生活中，日本的某个人根本不会是与他们有交集的人。
it took me two seconds to write to my colleague in Japan because I know somebody who lives there and had spent time with me in graduate school. I wrote a check immediately to the Red Cross and all of those actions happened. And this was in some foreign part of the world that in the lives of my grandparents and parents, somebody in Japan would simply not have been a person associated with them.
既然津村（Tsusumu）现在成为了我内群体的一部分，他住得那么远这一事实对救援行动来说就无关紧要了。马泽琳将发生的事情视为一个寓言，关于现代社会使什么成为可能。它们让我们有机会将外群体的人纳入内群体。但通过友谊扩大你的“我们”是有局限性的。还有其他一些灾难，马泽琳并没有做出反应，因为她没有感受到个人的
So now that Tsusumu is a part of my in-group, the fact that he lived so far away didn't matter to the act of helping. Maserine sees what happened as a parable about what modern societies make possible. They give us the opportunity to include people from the out group into the in group. But expanding the size of your us through friendships has limits. There were other disasters Maserine did not respond to because she did not feel a personal
联系。这确实让我开始思考，是否应该有一些规则来指导我如何做到这一点，这些规则不应基于触动心弦的事物，而是基于需求最大的地方，并以一种更中立的方式。约书亚说，人们有一个简单的方法来尝试扩大他们的联系圈。有可支配收入的人能做的最重要的一件事，就是向
connection. And it did make me wonder about having rules for how I might do this that are not based on what tugs at the heartstrings, but rather where the need is the greatest and in a more neutral way. Joshua says there is a simple way for people to try and expand their circles of connection. The number one thing that people who have disposable income can do is make a donation to
诸如“抗击疟疾基金会”（Against Malaria Foundation）这样的组织捐款。如果你捐赠3000美元，很有可能就能挽救某人的生命。这不是夸张。如果你和其他10个人每人捐出300美元，你就能挽救一条生命。或者另外100个人每人捐出30美元。这些都是普通凡人能够做到的真实事情。约书亚想到了他从哲学家威廉·麦卡斯基尔那里听到的一句话：如果你冲进一栋着火的建筑物并救了一个人的命，那将会是
an organization like the Against Malaria Foundation. If you condone $3,000, odds are you can save someone's life. That's not an exaggeration. And if you and 10 other people can each give $300, you can save someone's life. Or 100 other people will each give $30. Those are real things that ordinary mortal people can do Joshua thinks about something he heard from the philosopher Will McCaskill If you ran into a burning building and saved somebody's life that would be you know
你生命中的决定性时刻之一，你的余生都会铭记它，别人也会因此记住你。但大多数人，你知道的，只要赚取一份体面的专业薪水，你每年就可以拯救至少一两条生命，甚至都不用多想。我的意思是，我们拥有这种力量简直令人匪夷所思，但它却绝对是真实的。作为人类，我们的基因里被编程了巨大的爱与忠诚的能力。我们也有能力将整个世界视为我们的家庭。这两个系统都可以产生巨大的善意，同时也都有其自身的缺点。就像一个熟练的摄影师会根据她想要拍摄的照片来改变设置一样，
What if the defining moments of your life and you remember that for the rest of your life and other people would remember you buy it. But most people, you know, who earn a decent professional salary, you could say at least one or two lives every year and not even think much about it. I mean, it's mind-boggling that we have this power and yet it's absolutely true. As humans, we come programmed with an immense capacity for love and loyalty. We also have the capacity to see the entire world as our family. Both of these systems can produce immense good and both have made her shortcomings. Like a skilled photographer who changes her settings, depending on the photo she wants to take,
明智的做法是刻意选择我们的道德设置。本集节目由雷娜·科恩（Reina Cohen）和托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）制作。由塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）、卡特·舒克内希特（Kat Shuknecht）和帕尔塔·沙阿（Parthas Shah）编辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、劳拉·夸雷勒（Laura Quarelle）和卢·希库瓦巴（Lu Shikwaba）。工程支持来自吉利·穆恩（Gilly Moon）和约书亚·诺亚（Joshua Noah）。我们本周的“奔跑英雄”是约翰·兰辛（John Lansing）。约翰是NPR的首席执行官。他最近刚上任，就发现自己不得不应对全球大流行的影响以及非常紧张的新闻周期。
we would be wise to choose our moral settings deliberately. This episode was produced by Reina Cohen and Thomas Liu. It was edited by Tara Boyle, Kat Shuknecht and Parthas Shah. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Laura Quarelle and Lu Shikwaba. Engineering support from Gilly Moon and Joshua Noah. Our Ransang hero this week is John Lansing. John is NPR CEO. He recently came on the job only to find himself dealing with the effects of a global pandemic and a very intense new cycle.
过去几个月里，约翰以极大的同理心领导了NPR。他给人的印象是诚实、善良和直率。这正是一个优秀的领导者身上所应具备的品质。他也是“隐藏的大脑”（Hidden Brain）的粉丝，这无疑是个加分项。本集是关于道德决策的两部分系列节目的第二集。如果你错过了第一集，它叫做《证明手段的正当性》。想了解更多“隐藏的大脑”节目，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。如果你喜欢这集节目，请把它分享给朋友，或者更好的是，分享给一个陌生人。我挺好玩地想象着我们未来的孩子如果对这个感到刻薄，也许就像——我还不认识你呢，老兄，这不是针对个人的。我会向他解释为什么我们离火车远点。
John has steered NPR these past few months with great empathy. He comes across his honest, kind and direct. Exactly the qualities you want to see in a leader. It doesn't hurt that he's also a fan of Hidden Brain. This episode was the second in a two-part series on moral decision making. If you missed the first, it's called justifying the means. For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If you like this episode, please share it with a friend or better yet, with a stranger. I'm having fun imagining our future kid was mean to this and maybe like I didn't know you yet buddy it's not personal. I'll explain to him why we're staying away from trains.
我会向他解释为什么我们离火车远点。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam），这是NPR。本集节目尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
I'll explain to him why we're staying away from trains. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我会向他解释我们为什么要远离火车。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是美国国家公共电台。本期节目尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。